da habe ich schon mal was richtig damit
angestellt es geht hier so ghani und
heute gibt es diesen kleinen block da
ich in einer halben stunde von hier zu
hause los war und dann begebe ich mich
erstmal auf den weg nach göttingen
da werde ich mit meinem dad in meinem
bruder die nacht und den abend
verbringen weil es so ein termin von
meinem vater und morgen die zu weit
videopreis da ich jetzt aber nur so
kurze zeit hat welchem einfach fragen
beantworten und ich beginne einfach mal
damit wir machen es einfach einen
kleinen monjack habe ich heute ein video
kommen kann hier in meinem wunderbaren
aufbauen und ich will sowieso schon viel
spaß weil es einander sollte hat ist
weil es einfach unglaublich heißt es
dabei sieht es erstmal preschen klien
als mit einem auftritt mit seinem helm
einen auftritt
aber wir beginnen und zwar habe ich mich
fragen mit hashtags schweine pfote
fangen lassen mir fragen lassen
ok
ich glaube man sieht es daran wie ich
transpirieren traktor ist natürlich
alles nicht mal ein game mal gucken
anrückt solcher ich echt lächerlich bin
skeptisch
ähnlich wie ein tief von der marke
swatch bist du alle tage auf der
gamescom die parallel sind bin ich
natürlich beim video days weil ich finde
das interessant wie du dich irgendwie
als gamescom weil ich bin nicht so der
krasse spiele interessiert und wenn dann
sitzt du ein zwei spiele
aber ja ich bin nicht so krass geflasht
form von lieferscheinen video durch sein
versuch sich um 1 vorschlag swat t wie
werden diese 1 black druck vom team
sport macht wird es neue t shirts und
hoodies geben wenn du deinen neuen namen
hast das ziel ich vielleicht ein
bisschen bis ich den neuen namen ab aber
falls es das der fall sein sollte wird
es auf jeden fall neues geben weil ich
finde sowas krass persönlich ist und so
und das kann man einfach so cool aus
rücken und was man feiert und so was ich
selbst trage auch viel mehr ab so von
sollte beispiel habe ich mir zwei
politiker denken poster von ihm würde
seid ihr mit eurem momentanen leben
zufrieden sehr zufrieden ja ist ein
bisschen stressig mit der schule
wir haben schon fertig damit der
geldwäscherei sei nicht mehr geld geht
quasi gar nicht also ich wäre schon
gerne fertig mit der schule kriegt doch
ein ziemlich lahm
also ich werde du kannst du ja mit mir
ich wäre ja schon fertig mit der schule
aber das ist leider nicht der fall ein
jahr dann muss ich mich wohl noch
gedulden
eigentlich wäre ich ja schon fertig bla
bla bla bla bla ich glaube so viel wie
sonst nie
aber es wird trotzdem lustig habe ich
gefühlt weil er die fragen
hast du eine lieblingsfarbe blau war ich
mal so ihr müsst jetzt mal entscheiden
okay max kam an und ich habe gesagt ich
hab das erfahre ich ihm gesagt wäre es
noch so fest wie dieser bei und da hab
ich gesagt ja dein t-shirt ist zwar muss
erst mal komplett viel man sieht nur
mein oberkörper hat die hose die roses
blauth da gibt es habe ich keinen
zweifel
aber das t shirt ist schwarz und max
meinte das hier ist blau
ich würde sagen es gibt neun gates kanal
t shirt geld die certgate schreibt man
die klasse was geht bei euch die frage
ist ist das so es ist in schwarz oder
blau charts verein oder ist dunkelblau
und das ist dunkelblau schreibst du
heiraten oder das richtig damit
angestellt abgesprochen aber es sprechen
kommt es mal wieder nach frankfurt
was macht ihr an diesem wunderschönen
wochen habe ich bereits am anfang
erklärt also heute abend götting morgen
wird videopreis düsseldorf und dann im
laufe des abends noch andere orte aber
diesen wie deine künstler jo harbort
erstmal an bord aber es ist schon mal
ein ansatz gewesen die tracks peter ich
war an bord hat glaubt vier oder fünf
passieren aber schon seit jeher nur so
cruisen mäßig ich will dieses jahr gerne
mal anfangen mit downhills line
ermöglichen
bisher bin ich dazu gekommen
beziehungsweise hab es mir noch nicht
vorgenommen aber habe ich definitiv vor
wann startet mannschaft war eigentlich
und was ist euer plan
warum ich glaube man darf die genauen
daten nicht bekanntgeben
wobei den staat abgeben aber nicht mehr
aufnehmen
es startet am 18 sie bleibt also wasser
wasser wasser noch gefragt sie kommen
sie kommen sie konnten das tier sofort
mit baywatch ein handy das tut es gibt
ein rekord kälte lieber lutz als dein
vater oder deinen beruf hat junge ins
herz entfernt
mit diesen kranken familien früh ist
sehr offensichtlich die einfache diese
frage ich würd gern lud als meinen toten
opa haben aber noch nie in europa und
daher ist es nicht so 100% geschmacklos
nächste wahl hättest ihr auch mal lust
so eine große weltreise zu machen
liebe grüße liebe grüße größerer japan
macht freunde leben
ich kann mich steckt ein titel und es
war deine titten schlecker die anderen
können sie auch wie schlecht fühlen aber
wir hätten auf jeden fall boxen reisende
also reisen grundsätzlich ja solange
vielleicht wieder nicht aber hin und
wieder mal ein bisschen kribbeln ist
definitiv eine coole sache - tabelle
auch es ist da reißen das generell mehr
dabei war ihm kontra geschrieben das
nahe so gut war wie ich sie alle stellt
das war vor wenigen jahren bereicherte
frage hier jemand fragt wann kommt der
diskothek sich gegen congo after der 1
aber wir können das allein schaffen
machen der dispatcher letzter disstrack
ist einfach lust ist nummer 190 taugen
aber nur drei oder gebiet ist auch das
verbot spitzen frage würdest du mit js
und in einer wg mit nicht stimmt wir
können lud zu harry potter like und
kesha reinsch und politikerinnen
schwarzen jobcenter sieht ihr wisst was
ist bedeutet mein sport liebt die beiden
und mein gott will aber hier wieso
zweieinhalb minuten aber es kommt mir
vor als wäre ich aber macht euch die
noch einen fall geben
thematisch ist freien spitzen frage und
wichtigste frage von was ist wie weit
denkt delpierre in warschau jeweils ich
glaube ich werde es in war diesmal
hoffentlich zumindest durch das schwert
eines gegners sterben aber an sich soll
jetzt mal auch oberes drittel würde ich
würde ich sagen gerne weiter das sagte
eine frau will ihr dieses mal ist es das
letzte mal schon von prominenten getötet
brauchen ist eine axt sparen ist man
spart also so richtig so richtig legend
also wo ich auch cool bin ich mit dem
richtigen kampf sterben weil er vor
diese lava falle die blöden dann das
fucking direkt kate werden so tobias
siehst du ich sag ja eine sache junge
diesmal hast du perfekt
okay die ganzen kleinen wollten
aber ich darf sagen was man deckelt du
sagst du plötzlich wild erst folgen